all right phillip
welcome back
thank you great to see you again and
likewise
so one of my viewers
left a comment
on your first video
with a with a long list of questions
questions for you
we want to know more why is this not
surprising no no no they're not what
you'd expect well good
um oh they want a date no one's playing
what's her name her name's candy okay
candy renee it says um
can you expand expound on your childhood
a little more
i mean tell us about your i mean so you
had mom and dad growing up yeah my
typical question
yeah i lived my i lived with my parents
and my grandparents uh my mom's parents
because we all lived together
um
because
yeah my dad didn't have that much money
to
have his own place like that this was in
detroit right yeah
um so
and my brothers but no no terrible
traumatic events in your childhood none
none just i mean
being the middle child having the older
brother and the younger brother like
gang up on me uh but that was nothing
that's typical yeah sibling stuff yeah
and as for
my classmates i mean i was
what kind of kid were you in high school
rather popular i mean i'm not um
my sign was like in third grade
your personality was what we're seeing
today just a teenage version of it yeah
pretty much yeah which is very likeable
yeah
i i i would agree
i could see that it's hard to compliment
oneself without coming off something
like you know a braggart
i can imagine you being very popular in
high school yeah well i i had a circle
of friends and
i was tight with them and i was happy so
yeah i was yeah i was not a
outcast not a
yeah
another of candy's questions is what was
your worst childhood memory
um
my grandfather dying when i was 10. yeah
it's gotta be bad um it was a year-long
battle with cancer
and just the the decline
was a whammy 84 was a bad year
because that's when my grandfather
passed
and
two dogs
that we had died on the same day
and what was your best childhood memory
um
we did family vacations like um
down to gatlinburg tennessee and one
year and
up to northern michigan
one year like in the upper peninsula and
just
going on trips like that and
that was fun it helped
foster a sense of you know adventure and
travel that i still had to this day yes
most people have good memories of those
childhood trips
all right so now that now the questions
get a little little meatier okay when
were you first exposed to sex
i think you told us i mean well in 14
was when i
but um
yeah and
like about learning the birds and bees
was
a couple years before then
um
and there was no talk that my dad gave
or anything like that there was a
book and i guess that's what
how
they introduced the topic to us was like
here's a book it was in your like
bookshelf i don't know how it got there
why don't you read it or something like
that
i'll read this yeah so that was it and
me being independent always
has been that way
um
[Music]
just pursued it myself like i said uh
the summer before i started high school
where i just wanted to be sure who i was
yeah and i found out
you're curious yeah you're a curious
person
yeah and because
if i don't know and that's part of the
um
drawbacks i guess i have about myself is
that i am
insistent on being right so if i'm not
right i'm going to research it to find
out what is right and then boom there it
is
um
yeah so i just apply that to myself also
a lot i mean if i don't know something
i'm going to pursue it research it
get in depth and
yeah find out what it's like have you
ever seen a therapist
oh yeah
i saw
a as a kid and i don't know why
um
i waxed my brain trying to figure out
what made me
warrant
uh
therapy as a kid but i remember going to
a place and
talking to someone and not really
enjoying myself because i mean they were
kind of boring
but um yeah
i still can't tell you to this day and
mom whenever i've tried to bring up the
subject i don't remember you going there
really you don't remember taking me to
the little
place and
yeah so
a lot of stuff is
not discussed not
talked about right in the family
and it just assumed that
it happened move on and we don't have to
revisit anything if it wasn't anything
negative right
um
do you consider your
your view on sex healthy
no
i mean
yeah
no why not well
it was too
risky for too long
because i put myself in some
dangerous positions but i came out
unscathed yeah you're lucky but yeah
exactly because if things went a little
bit differently
might not be here
so
i like
that i
did experience it
so maybe i don't have to rebel
you know like midlife crisis or anything
like that that you know i figured out
that years ago i had my midlife crisis
when i was 12. you experienced
everything you wanted to experience
as a young man yeah
and so having that
[Music]
instilled in me
helped
in some ways
and even with sex i mean
it helped me learn
what
felt good what did not
what
where limits were sure my limits my my
my
too far is a lot further than other
people
but
i don't mind i mean
there's people out there that are worse
i'm sure a lot of people are sexually
repressed and that's yeah and that that
manifests itself in a lot of terrible
ways i mean you see
look at all the idiots that do the the
shootings you know because they never
got laid oh my god i can't
imagine the
what is it called the in-cells
involuntary celibate
that they say they never had none
because they have no social skills no no
ability to
talk or just be a real people make a
connection yeah
and i those people scare me i mean i can
you know remember some
growing up and just some that yeah
they're like a little red flag in my
head like they are
and yeah
and most i would i would assume that
probably comes from some kind of
treatment they got their childhood from
their parents it could be and i
couldn't fault them but i knew not to
antagonize or
demean because i don't like that
i'm not like that
that's not helpful no i mean and
treating everyone
with the same respect that you want for
yourself that golden rule thing kind of
is something that i've always lived by
even though it wasn't
indoctrinated in me it was just
something that was innate
that's what growing up in
the biggest blackest city in america was
is there anything other than sex that
you're passionate about that you're
interested in
travel
um music i used to play the saxophone
for years oh really yeah the alto and
tenor and baritone
love baritone that's the big heavy one
and the deepest sound one that was neat
um
[Music]
i like creativity i'm a pisces so that
comes naturally
to us
and that's me
i
i like to be creative
and so that
can be
seen in many ways
were you closer to your mom or your dad
my mom i would say because
we were both pisces she was poor
birthdays 10 days after mine
and my father
he was
a good man
he passed away by late 2018 and
it's been
sad
um
there was
a distance that i had
put myself
from my family in in terms of
that's why i went to college 500 miles
away i guess so i could have that
finally
independence that i long wanted even
though i was independent in high school
i mean i would take the car you know
when i could drive
and i mean i would go out to
you know with friends or
on little adventure trips of my own you
know in the area
um
but i
was always about self discovery being
a lone wolf but an independent one not a
recluse but i mean just someone that
had to pursue things on his own yeah are
you more similar to your mom or dad
personality was mom i'd say
um
i got a little of both in me
yeah but um i would have to say if you
had to pick one or the other would be
mom
and candy's next question is when was
the last time you cried
oh god a couple days ago
at longest
i'm uh
it comes with the territory of being
someone that is
empathetic someone that feels someone
that
yeah i just
can't remember why
last time did you feel like an outcast
when you were young when you were a kid
you were just going i knew there was
something
different about me than other people
but i tried to
tamper that down by being
more outgoing and being you know the
person that you see
um that that
friendly
likable
type person
i
i wouldn't say i went out of my way
to present that
because i liked being you know
that nice person so therefore any oddity
that was felt
i kept to myself
i mean like something like if
anyone asked any personal questions and
be like no
you know because
i'm not going to divulge that
not until i talk to you buddy
so guys so uh free to
explain i mean i would not
lie per se but
i wouldn't be as forthcoming because
it's really nobody's business who does
what
boy
at some point i mean maybe it was the
five years of abject you know
homelessness
that led to the justin sander that
finally led me to the apartment you know
right across the street as you know
and falling into you last year but
i
or maybe just gotten older and
less
uh uh concerned you know i'm just this
is me take me as i am
comes of age
it comes with age yeah
i like that and with age because come
wisdom does come
more
securing yourself yeah and therefore
that's what probably led me to just be a
little more
comfortable with being who i am which is
awesome with a capital a yes you are
when was the last time you felt complete
candy asks hmm
dang candy you should be a journalist
yeah another good question yeah
but i felt complete
i can't
you don't have to say there was a time i
really
am hard pressed to come up with a time
um i would say when
it was in a stable long-term
relationship
and which was oh god
over 10 years ago
i liked that time frame you know i felt
most
yeah the the latter part of my detroit
days
which would be like oh five did that
have anything to do with sex
um you just felt no just my job was
going very well um i
the last
two years at my job up there
i was on a special project away from the
union work which i'm
doing stuff in a department where the
salary was double the amount i was
making
and the goal was for me to try and
improve you know in the big corporate
world
and for the two years i was on a special
project that i
created because i saw
the
gaps
and what's preventing me from doing my
job best
and when i have senior management or
vice presidents that are like well
you've got to do it this way and if
you're going to fill out a formal
employee satisfaction make sure you
answer it this way like
no
and during this employee staff meeting
of like
a couple hundred people
and
the vice president my vice president
because she was one of the
three or four vice presidents that we
had
but one that would be directly over my
area
she was there
and
i basically um made a smart comment
that
unfortunately was a little too loud he's
like um what are you trying to say and
well i got kind of caught so i'm like
trying to express that hey
things are not as rosy as you like to
think they are
it can't be done this way there's
problems i'd love to show them to you
okay she says it's a great employee in
my book
i it was a good
job
if you knew how to play the game right
because i mean this is big corporate i
was in a union part
of it
and when you're union
your hands are tied but
if you follow the rules and just shut up
and you don't go along
you can make a long career out of it and
make damn good money
because when i left this was in 08
but at that time i was making 50 000 a
year and that was bring home
you know like when you add up all the
every pay period
um
yeah it's like
1800 for two weeks that would be
my guy with my salary you know like
after taxes
so that was nice
and so
but i was not
content with that because i saw
that the job could wear me out and and
make me go postal
so to speak not not really because i
no i can't do guns or anything but
there was um a lot of stress that came
with it because that's where
um anxiety came in i mean i would have
panic attacks
at the job
and but they didn't give you a promotion
after that um
after that two year project and it was
like phil everything's going exactly the
way you thought it would be like and
there was a noticeable improvement in
our customer service our uh call volumes
you know and things from
improvements or acros all measures that
they love were there so after the two
years of doing that i'm like hey what's
up with that promotion that you know we
were trying to do
oh sorry it's not in the budget what
what so to speak
well had i
really put two and two together i could
have
been a little more
patient for like a month because it was
contract with negotiation time with the
union
and
who's to say that if because the
contract was you know approved and
whatnot
that
since that then allowed their budgeting
to be done differently
maybe there could have been something
who knows but with the way that they
made it sound so final i said myself you
know after they said not in the budget
i said myself my head you know [ __ ] you
because i've done this for you and
within a week i decided that
i was going to get out as soon as
possible
and that was to move you know halfway
across the country
with my ex
is there anything that makes you totally
happy other than sex at this point in
your life
well i mean the small things like um
good friendships
you know the
platonic ones with you know other guys
that you know or you know
having an interpersonal connection
not sexual related right is a very
nice thing yeah
hard to find
which is why sometimes i like to be
alone
we talked about this before being down
here in skid row you're not going to
find a whole lot of people to do that
with yeah there's not
like there's more than what you would
think but not nowhere near the amount
that i would like yeah
because they're not
falling out of the woodwork but they're
there you're you're pretty evolved and
intelligent and it's like you're amongst
a crowd of people that are
i have felt
and this helps thank you for help
triggering something
i have long felt in order to
be happy
i had to dump myself down
and so
even when i try to dumb myself down
they can see uh
maybe based on my
word choice or whatever it is that that
your behavior there is something that's
more
learned than the average bearer
but i mean
i'm not gonna go around
acting like i'm the smartest person in
the room but at the same time i'm not
so quick to
point out my
higher level thinking skills i guess
but
because you're not arrogant about it
no
that i'm not
i'm too a fault
because then like i said
i dumb myself down to the point where
have i really become that dumb on
certain things but
i think
with the most intelligent people like
einstein or whatever there's
they got a lot of dumb things that
they'll do
and i can see that
and i that's why i do dumb things
maybe yeah
because i'm smart yeah that sounds funny
one of one of candy's questions are you
a sex addict is it do you consider it an
addiction
at one point it was yeah at one point it
definitely was
like when you're
leaving your house at like 10 11 p.m and
just trolling the streets to see if you
can pick up anything
yeah
um
i'm like going to the
uh
central bus depot like where all the
different city buses meet up at and
whatnot
just to pick up someone yeah
in the middle of the night yeah
and stuff like that
uh winding up
uh um
going to someone's
little hovel
crack house apartment
um
for the sole purpose of sex rather than
you know drugs or anything else
i yeah i was putting myself in dangerous
positions
like
yeah
that that
what was the question i forgot are you a
sex addict oh yeah that would have been
like the the occurrences where
that sex addiction was front and center
when you're when you're putting yourself
in danger that's probably yeah
having that long-term relationship that
i was talking about that lasted seven
years
was
stabilizing mostly
and i grew a lot out of it
um
i'm not so quick to you know uh
getting the freaky dicky
you know randomly
when it is it's planned out a little bit
more than it was before
i don't know if it just comes with age
or what but i mean again that is
i'm not as crazy as i was how was he
um how old do i look
40. oh bless your [ __ ] i'm 47 47
is your sex drive what it used to be
um
let's just say it was like this for
years and years and years and years but
now it's like this
wow
it was here but now it's here yeah and
it's still here
it's jumping down just um
it always stays up
no no no no
and candy's last question is uh do you
love yourself i'm sure the answer is yes
or no
the answer is
ness i mean yo
it's a full mixture of both because
i do
love
me at my core
but
the things that i do
just in general not necessarily sexually
related but that too
everything sometimes it's like what the
hell
i do know
that when i had
the
horrible hell medical hell of 2010
uh that's where i was hospitalized for
three months
and
lost part of my brain because of the uh
brain infection and the of the fever and
the meningitis and the
everything else i had all five
concurrent
major illnesses that can take a person
down i had them at the same time
blood clots
uh stuff like that
um
the legs lungs and brain and
for me to have survived that
i mean i know that there has been
a shift
in
me
since 2010 you know since all that
happened
uh
the most
clearest waves is i don't drink anymore
i used to drink liquor fish i mean drink
anyone under the table
and when i got out of the hospital i
would try it and
no i don't like alcohol beer wine
shots i mean it
was nothing i really got into
until recently
i had like a damn [ __ ]
you know beer from the store and
it was not bad but i don't see myself
wanting to become
a you know fish with it again yeah but
something things like that um my
personality did change in some aspects
because people like
what's wrong with you like
some things just don't click right now
the synapses in my brain are not the
same as they were
they're humbled together the best that
they can be
and so
it is what it is
i can't
be upset
because
i am what i am and
if i'm gonna
be all right with myself
i have to accept myself and
that's why i love myself
excellent yeah yeah
you're a fascinating guy oh thank you
i'm
i still get to see how i'm thinking but
thank you
i mean your personality is just
very easy to get comfortable with well
thank you thank you much i appreciate
that it helps me realize the good in me
that can win
and not let the ugliness
i have a lot more dark thoughts than i
used to oh really
not about self-harm but you know just
a loss of
desire to make a positive difference in
the world because it's like why bother
when you see the global warming when you
see the war and all these other things
that are just ready to destroy us any
day now or any year now
it's a lost cause and i have lost
that kind of faith and hope and humanity
but
i will still
not
make it worse
you know
for others but
i don't see i'm not being
one that's going to strive to make a
difference
because that's right
it's very sad
i feel bad for young kids now yeah
growing up without if i were growing up
now i would probably be a lot more
suicidal like why would there be a
reason to live i'm not going to live
not at care age or anything like that
um
and become a lot more
aloof or whatever who knows because i
mean
well i am based on what my parents did
so i mean it's hard to say how i am
going to be as a kid now because what my
parents were like yeah see when i was a
kid i remember
having hopes and dreams of of being the
very best at whatever i wanted to do in
life yeah and the world becoming a great
place and everyone
you know wars ending and yeah like that
was everything great happening in the
world and now these kids i think a lot
of people adults and kids alike
don't have that they're just like
they're thinking it's going down the
tubes yeah and so
the question is
are we
able to
stop the cycle of madness
are we going to perpetrate it
you know and make it
compounded worse
i mean
i don't want to get political but that's
kind of how it plays out well i mean it
plays into religion plays in politics it
plays into education it plays into
poverty plays yeah everything is part of
it and
yeah and i think if
you know it's not you can't take a whole
group and fix them all but but if you
fix one and two and three and four and
we all kind of do our part
then we can
eventually make a difference i would
hope so and part of me still wants to
believe that which is why
i try to keep that i'm eternally
optimistic yeah well i can't say that i
am anymore but i
having
a good
core
set of friends
like ones that you can just shoot the
[ __ ] with like this
help
and i feel for those that don't have
that type of
connection with someone well i mean like
i i've interviewed thousands of people
now
and it's very you know every once in a
while i can connect with somebody like i
do with you but i can't do that with
everyone i mean some of these people i
give them the formulaic questions and
they just give me the their their their
story which is interesting and i post
those videos but i'm not making
connections with these people i just
couldn't and my personality and theirs
just don't
jive like that whereas yours and mine
i could talk with i could spend all
night with you talking mm-hmm you know i
guess i could go on a vacation with you
because i find you interesting and
you're you're you're very pleasant to be
around
but i can't say that about everyone i
can say that about very few people
but there's a handful of people that are
just man i just i enjoy them i enjoy
seeing them every time they come by it's
always a pleasure to run into you on the
street or whatever like that so i'm glad
that you invited me over and
had me catch up and
i hope you're not disappointed candy
all right
candy renee thank you very much for your
questions thank you phillip for
answering them yeah thank you that was
fun thanks cool thanks tata for now
you